نحن نجلس في مساحة كاديلاك الداخلية ،
إنها مركبة مفهوم إنها 20 30
وما بعدها إنها رؤية للمستقبل
لذا يمكنك أن ترى أنه لا توجد عجلة قيادة
في السيارة ، لذا فهي
مركبة مستقلة كهربائية بالكامل ومستقلة بالكامل من
المستوى الخامس وإذا  لاحظت
في المقاعد هنا
مستشعرًا بيولوجيًا ، لذا فإن كل شيء هو تجربة سلسة بديهية للغاية ،
لذا كعميل ،
ستفهم تفضيلاتك
ومن أنت حتى تتمكن من الجلوس في
المقعد ، حيث يقرأ المستشعر البيومتري بياناتك
الحيوية ، وربما يكون معدل ضربات قلبك  مرتفع
أو شيء ما ننظر إليه
كمثال لتجربة التأمل في الوقت الحالي ،
إنها تجربة متعددة الحواس ، فهناك
موزع للرائحة في السيارة بالإضافة
إلى مكبرات الصوت للصوت والمرئيات
والتكتيكات في المقعد وكذلك
[الموسيقى]
لذا نعم  يعتبر مفهوم كاديلاك بين الفضاء
جزءًا من سيارة عائلية ، لذا هناك
مساحة شخصية ، وهي عبارة عن حق نقض بمقعد
واحد يطير ومساحة اجتماعية تبلغ
حوالي ستة مقاعد ، لذلك هذا هو جو  st
لشخصين مثلك كما ذكرت ، ويمكنك
أيضًا أن تكون شخصًا واحدًا ، لذا فهي
تجربة مختلفة تمامًا
مقارنة بالمركبات الأخرى
[موسيقى]